video games
i think the gameplay is more important
than
the equity in the brand
so for example like americans didn't
give a [ __ ] about soccer but we became
obsessed with fifa oh yeah yeah oh yeah
same thing happened with hockey games
like yeah i ain't gonna [ __ ] about
hockey but the games were lit the game
play was so dope that like i was
invested in yeah and
i think that's probably like mario kart
a little bit like so but that's an
interesting thing like
you develop a game
around this brand that's bigger than the
game yeah but if the game is lit you
don't need to be
coughing off this money to double 07 in
the james bond enterprise yeah because
even if james bond wasn't there if it
was just
called zero dark thirty or some others i
think you need the hook you need that so
the hook gets us in
like a brand sponsor pokemon was a car
game for mad long but i feel like it
didn't pops a little bit but then what's
the one that these kids play now that
they're killing each other they fly off
the helicopter overnight fortnite like
that had no hook
and it [ __ ] demolished it was free
though yeah that was like the first one
that went free games or free no no no no
no you paid money for yeah
fortnite
[Music]
on your xbox for free which is smart
because make money through the other
things and they make crazy money off
skins and other [ __ ] yeah selling fake
in-game products jesus i didn't know
that and then they had the whole thing
with the loot boxes where like you're
basically gambling in the game and they
like cut it out
i heard about this yeah they the app
stores threatened to but it's like
actual gambling whereas like okay i'm
gonna put an x amount of money and then
there's a percentage i could win this
other [ __ ] yeah but not money right just
loot or whatever yeah i think it was
just luke but then you could trade loot
and like sell it
and gain money that way i'm pretty sure
i don't know i don't really play
fortnite that much
we're talking gaming right now this is
your wheelhouse right now you lured him
back in
was it card game cartoon or video game
uh pokemon was big in japan came here
and then yeah it was like uh card game
was big here and then
the anime came at the same time pokemon
is a great like mall video game like
like you know what it is though like
oh you didn't hear us through that whole
story oh
yes
so that mall [ __ ] bro that [ __ ] really
how did that make you feel like when
mark just [ __ ] all over the outfit that
you meticulously put together you were
looking cool
like stop
cool stop can we get married in the mall
like it's cool
[Laughter]
nothing wrong with the mall where do we
go surfing
i just heard you guys talking stupid
about video games thank you no yeah he
came in for the video he's talking about
the advancement remember [ __ ] all over
he called you a mall it's a mall skate
brand fun i just ghosted him for like a
week i didn't talk to him damn
yeah yo get in there
[Applause]
that's
are you in your feelings no i'm just not
a professional comedian i can't out talk
him well he's not a professional he's
more like a fall community
that was good
crazy
[Music]
[Music]
bound no big bill
big big bread
big dick
guys that was crazy
bro
damn damn bro damn hold on with the
eaves
heavy no more bro you're a light boy
because i went on a vacation to slim
down you light bro how do you lose
weight on vacation i don't know i tried
it
my girl was shooting me from the titties
up for the last like five days of the
goddamn vacation
bro
i took a video on a mountain with my
shirt open and she was like uh button it
i was like damn
he's so honest what was his honesty
don't ever let him talk about your
clothing like that again